Oh decal that's what this parts war
we're going to general on the other
stuff oh yeah I mean Amazon Apple Google
Facebook the reason they're so big is
their - Tollbooth in the internet right
so in the past the Rams were out on the
street street fighting for the people in
Vancouver
then well not I genuinely believe that
7/11 and Burger King or deep [ __ ] in a
thirty year window this is about timing
you're very thoughtful I've listened a
couple of times like everybody here I
will tell you the biggest thing that
I've gotten better at the lessons I
learned as a kid even though I was right
I literally built my dad's entire
business strategy for Wine Library when
I took over ninety nine eight I'm not
the this this is true that by the year
2000 which is 24 months from then
everybody would walk into our liquor
store with a phone and have technology
that would give them the price of every
product in the country in order of best
price and that's literally how I decided
to sell everything a cost that anybody
knew and then build up other brands it
was great because it really worked
because we were the price leader of
every wine anybody wanted we still don't
do that
it is now 2019 we have closest
capability we have that capability ish
there is something called wine searcher
if you're a big wine buyer that
aggregates like it it's there but it's
not one person will walk into wine
library this year that's by where people
look up stuff on Amazon you know so I
was wrong about timing what I got better
what I'm good at now people you know so
right I'm good at timing that's why I
didn't bet on VR that's why I don't bet
on AR that's why I don't bet on machine
learning or things of that nature
I know every one of those things is
gonna happen the question is when right
so yes what you're saying is right the
question for you is how are you
overthinking it so would I say you
should go buy a bunch of buildings you
and for your restaurants like that may
not work but when that's at scale when
when ordering food
Alexa is that scale or Google you could
be talking about a good 7 10 years could
be more I think that's the if you know I
don't I don't I'm guessing that feels
ish you know you start thinking about
SEP you know here's what you have to
look at who's doing it all the time if
anybody here has read to nine-year-old
kids in their life they definitely see
that those humans think about voice very
differently than we do so in seven eight
years when they're you know in high
school and have the capability of having
like some money whatever we're gonna
start doing things differently that's
how everything happens that's how online
dating happened unlike Danny was around
for a long time it didn't become
acceptable until the generation that
only talked them aim and all that guff
got it
so you have to look at consumer behavior
I'll tell you the bigger thing is gonna
be the infrastructure of last mile who's
gonna deliver it so for example I think
there's gonna be a ton of restaurants
that don't have a physical location that
are just sitting under buildings and
I've contemporary that's right that's
what everybody's gonna be no I think
brings the only thing left as money is
there now like I think that to your
point
Alexa or Google or phone send me a
cheeseburger but there will be brands
that say send me a Shake Shack burger or
McDonald's or Burger King I think I
don't think brand has to go away I think
you're making a valid point but I don't
think you you realize how many people
don't buy based on brand like people
like the amount of people here who
bought a cheeseburger and they actually
didn't give a [ __ ] it was just the first
one in the airport that had a
cheeseburger and whether it was Tim
Hortons McDonald's you know Burger King
or something else they didn't care
Labatt's every day that's why private
labels are doing well right and
convenience is king but brand is queen
and she runs [ __ ] the amount of brands
allowed are completely predicated on how
well brands are executed so I think
store you got to think about what one
right like like a cheeseburger I mean
everybody like look I think you're gonna
buy your toothpaste you're gonna buy it
from Alexa and it's going to be in your
home within three minutes that's awesome
you know buying a [ __ ] pair of
sneakers that way is not awesome for a
lot of people still people want to see
it and touch it like so though you have
to figure out what commodities are in
trouble if 7-elevens in trouble
convenience stores and bodegas are in
trouble I really believe that we overpay
everybody here has paid more for
something that they knew they could buy
somewhere else because it was right
there instead you didn't drive to
Walmart or Costco or sate spit right
well that convenience is about to get
really convenient
so it's convenience its brand right
there's all the same things that have
always dominated humans will always play
so I'm obsessed with brand because with
voice to your point I pull up a Google
search in 2003 when that was dug game
even you might have been better I was
the best at it why my brain was better
than everybody even wine.com
I was better than everybody that's why
we've got big but people still saw their
store that they were actually looking
for and not me below right they stay
typed in Cabernet they wanted to buy
from the supermarket they saw the Wine
Library ad I got a lot of them but I
think everybody and they would go to
where they wanted here if I save wine
Amazon controls that so what I needed
them to say is Wine Library
that's why brand is so important right
because if they're gonna say send me
supplements I want creatine you're
finished because you're not to be able
to afford the affiliate fee the amount
of money that Google Apple Amazon or
whoever else wins this is going to be
able to charge brands like Rickard to be
to be the default brand are gonna make
slotting fees and stores look like a
[ __ ] picnic hundred percent 100
percent 100 percent
they'll be strategic they'll they'll do
what they've always done they'll pick
and choose if if records willing to
really pay the big [ __ ]
we'll get to whatever shave whatever in
three years but if nobody's willing to
pay [ __ ] it we'll do it ourselves or
they're gonna look at data everyone's
asking for shampoo it's now a viable
enough thing for us to do our own
shampoo voice is a big one because it's
not visual this you won't still gave us
options voice we're gonna have no
control other than one thing
grant Alexis send me Twinkies not
chocolate cupcakes that matters that's
why I keep building brain
so I brand this forever course and and
the quality where to your point and that
is examples where the quality you had a
big enough advantage in the actual
consumers point of view not your own
where a lot of brands are gonna lose and
why they lost the private label game is
they assume that the quality Delta was
going to be enormous and in some
categories it wasn't so correct your R&D
capabilities or the Delta a convenience
is a son of a [ __ ] boy
it's a [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] their
people literally go into a st. Spurrier
Walmart or market wanting to buy your
product but because it's one shelf lower
and this one's here and they know they
don't like it as much it just [ __ ]
they don't have the second for you it's
crazy how to be a brand that makes
somebody willing to be inconvenient is
the [ __ ] Holy Grail how are you so
good that I'm willing to go out of my
way to have you
yeah that's the real answer 433 I know
all about it
yeah yep you know the sort of place most
engaging she wants it's the most
important platform and you're one of the
most important products on the platform
is huge yeah at the moment but eternally
we discussed if we have but that was
also my question and what about other
channels are the focus we have a
community where the fans yeah I'll it's
so crazy I don't think so this is
literally the post I just posted on
Instagram this morning I think my post
is something like if incident
disappeared today so would 98% of you
because everyone's so one-dimensional
what should you do you should start a
podcast 365 days a year you should post
two times a day on YouTube you should
figure out the business version and put
on LinkedIn you should start your own
text messaging platform you should build
up your own email just you need the
platform's because you've their
attention when you siphon it and you
need your own first party data email and
texting because you need to own
own platform just yeah be sure
4:33 calm yep just even the traffic and
the cookies and the first party data all
of it
events yep apparel mm-hmm and the beauty
is you you're in a great spot that's the
answer to everybody yeah you have
something big already
you just have to throw right hooks in
four three three look at my partner I
always say watch what I you know look
what I'm doing like I'm booked like
three posts again that post I took five
years ago ring point because I want you
to turn on my notifications like I'm
always gathering attention right you
know putting the final touches on my new
text messaging platform I had it for a
wild person line the tech wasn't strong
about the reroll roll it out then when i
reroll it out and you'll see it I'm
gonna throw right up like one poster
just could be a black box with a phone
number look that's gonna be the post I
don't give a [ __ ] that it's gonna get
22,000 likes instead of 200,000 I want
the [ __ ] phone numbers people get
caught up in [ __ ] literally I know
this happens in your company whether
it's you or somebody else you care so
much about winning the day on a post on
Instagram you're not siphoning out the
IP you know this is what happens
like your next post should be like sign
for email list it's not going to do as
well as the [ __ ] clips but it's gonna
be much more valuable for your business
you're pandering to Instagram there were
people that were the biggest on MySpace
- yeah please who are the people that
buy these things
understood of course yes I understand to
really get the rider and really get the
dad to your point you got it
it's Instagram link and LinkedIn or
Instagram and Facebook or snapping for
you but the creative the math everything
is fundamentally different it's just
being in the mindset of actually
marketing to both of them and being good
back to being a good footballer like you
might be better at LinkedIn than you are
an instrument you know I'm better at
video than I am written word right so I
think but yes of course you can do that
and I'm very bullish on LinkedIn
advertising yeah I really am I for
consumer goods to LinkedIn is underrated
they built [ __ ] Facebook and there's
businesspeople in there and all you have
to do is if you're selling them soap
make it about how efficient their
business day will be if they use
yourself you know like you have to make
it contextual people always talk about
awareness but they don't talk about
relevance and the biggest problem is
everybody talks about awareness as
potential awareness versus actualized
awareness so what I love about Facebook
and Instagram and YouTube it's actually
being consumed
and you can actually make contextual
creative for it that's why it's so much
better
psycho and demo right and the platform's
have that information but like like you
know in LinkedIn that the person works
at RBS or went to Cambridge or like you
know I don't know I don't know how
people haven't figured this out like to
the I when I say haven't figured out app
I think we do a bad job of layering
common sense it's so effective the
problem is nobody realized how much
creative it took that's where everybody
got [ __ ] included it took me a little
while it's just so much creative look
back to personal brand for some of you
like some of the stuff we're starting to
it's like hey Detroit
hey Texas like this stuff I'm doing for
empathy except in front of 20 minutes
and did like 73 different beginnings hey
did you [ __ ] up look this is literally
one hey did you [ __ ] up Valentine's Day
we're running that right now don't ever
[ __ ] that up again what our subscription
of wine you know have to think about
buying her a gift anymore dudes you know
hey look it's you know we literally
picked the highest network counties in
America literally from Wikipedia just
like probably clean-ish data and I just
was like hey Huntington Beach hey
Somerville hey hundred it's like
literally and then you run it and it
converts better but when everybody else
did was what I did for years
hey everybody should pick up this wine
run to everybody
think about a few guys who made
contextual creative as Instagram add to
just the football team that person
actually liked I don't look at Patriot
highlights on my football it's Graham
accounts you know
[Music]
and then you can make the inside joke of
razzing the rival right now you're
relevant when the I mean literally when
you see a LinkedIn ad that says hey Dad
do you have a daughter here's what's
really cool though about going abroad if
your LinkedIn ad said hey Meg dad do you
have a daughter that rides but what's
interesting is you LinkedIn and Facebook
do not have that data for the most part
but if you go high net worth if you go
into cliche write that human if it's a
good piece of creative is gonna pass
that on to his nephew whose daughter
rides or is bought you know that's
what's amazing about so here you nobody
rips out a [ __ ] newspaper ad and
brings it nothing you know like think
I'm right we're watch as a commercial
takes out their phone the cords info but
people do pass on social creative that's
good but okay do you know about this
company see where I'm going yeah so
there's that's the reason to go broad
social media is special I just don't
understand how people don't see it and
I'm a little face it's hard it's hard
it's new it's it's the it's the reverse
of the old world it's literally the
reverse
it's all bottom up instead of top down
so it just doesn't come natural to
people because most people are not
consumer centric it came natural to me
because I grew up in a retail store
selling knocking door-to-door it was
only the customer
there was no academia there was no
thesis there was no consulting and it
was always I was always on the hook even
people that are Street kids that go into
companies immediately aren't on the hook
so that's how I got there you know it's
taken a while for me to realize why but
that's the game
got anything by the way on that back to
cuz you set it up the answer is yes you
just run a marathon when you have to be
profitable what you're gonna learn
that's why I think we've got the model
down and you'll do it internally with us
somebody else is you'll get math that
works for you you just won't be able to
scale it in a way that somebody who's
losing money every day could scale it
but as somebody who competed against
wine.com that had 168 million dollars in
funding and I had nothing and I won it's
because 2000 happened when the world
melts all these DTC brands are finished
finished they're completely built on the
next round until they sell it to one of
you and I think you guys and you you
know but like macro CPG big brands are
finished cuz channel conflict because
sync it's deja vu the best bet I ever
made was when the internet collapsed I
was only 24 years old all the stock
market collapsed April 2000 dead right
my bought Amazon because it was the
first time I understood that Wall Street
because I didn't know was different than
real life Amazon was gonna win but Wall
Street did different [ __ ] what you know
cuz it's just a what and that's when I
figured it out that's what's gonna
happen shit's gonna hit the fan tomorrow
everyone's gonna melt Proctor and J&J
and Pepsi are all gonna high-five and be
like see [ __ ] those [ __ ] but in the
ashes are gonna be the actual companies
that put them out of business which is
why you should do that meaning just
build something that's profitable that's
it that's it
your biggest the two biggest things you
have to do is make sure creative and
math and insights are working together
not separate and you make a fuckload of
credit the biggest issue for them at
four six and twelve dollars it's how
many creative variables the agencies
making that's it
so targets right 23 year old dudes the
[ __ ] shortage is not hard I thought
you were going with R&D products Oh 100%
especially if you do our indie that way
don't guess I would literally create a
channel on social media called make
pretend products and just post everyday
and see what people give a [ __ ] about
and then go make that orange juice with
coconut oil
why guess you had a guess because there
was no way the internet didn't exist so
yes I would but I would do it the way I
just said I'm wouldn't guess unless
strategy right you guys are a big
company
if Unilever or J&J or Proctor has
something that you're pissed off about
and there's a good reason they're like
[ __ ] with them like hims you know you
know like things like that just a [ __ ]
cuz you're because you're you know
fighting a war say like you know what
let's go [ __ ] around in that battle that
could be a lodge you know a place where
you could lose and still win right like
if I was running a big conglomerate I
would look at the place where my biggest
competitor is winning I would make a
product that I was gonna lose money on
with the sole reason of making that
brand seem not cool to the end-user if I
felt the talent within that company just
would be able to not just drive that
business but drive the DNA of the full
organization if I was like these guys
are so dynamic and when I bought that
I'd be like look I'm gonna pay twice
what you're getting 4050 million offers
I'm gonna give you a hundred a hundred
but I'm not giving you dick until the
end I'm gonna give you five now and 95
and year for contractual like we can't
fire you you'll get it all and the four
years you have to change the DNA of the
organization I don't give a [ __ ] if your
little thing grows I need to [ __ ] fix
this
yes by the way it's super smart can if
you can figure out how to not let
anybody be the judge of the creative you
will win who is it who's the judge in
your world the co-founder two bosses
somebody like who is it that's your
problem that's that's that's your
problem
that's them
then then then you pound them yes you
educate them that they're subjective
call is the vulnerability it's back to
humility it's back to the wonderful
question he asked like why doesn't that
frustrate you because he meant because I
have more humility than I have ego I
mean I'm putting out content about me
forget about empathy or [ __ ] a hotel
or a sneaker or shaving cream or a
vitamin and I'm wrong all the time
it's me I read all my qualms and I'm
long enough
that's what proved to be like if that's
happening with me who nobody's deeper in
the quant that I'm in add it to me and
I'm producing it and I know and I'm
wrong game over
I mean that's exactly right and then
just you know what I think what I do
well is I get to the punchline quick
right if you go to the punchline quick
and I keep pointing because I'm just so
excited because I'm curious it's gonna
be awesome to see what you do or don't
do but it is the punchline if you sit
down the two founders would be like and
this depends on if you're willing to get
fired having a good enough relationship
but if somebody just says hey Joe and
Johnny here's the punchline your
subjective [ __ ] call and if that's
cool or not cool good or bad means
nothing the end that doesn't mean you
can't have like you know when people
hear me say that I go well Gary what
about the guy who said if I listen to my
customers I would have made fast four
horses then I would say good then you
would put out the car the car would have
worked then everybody would agree back
to businesses and products so if they're
so right
let them post four times a day you don't
by the way you want to really work it
don't post on the Instagram account run
them as ads and see what actually works
you can run a thousand pieces of
Instagram content a day run them as ads
they don't show up on the main page it's
why everybody loves stories everybody
puts the main feed on such a pedestal
like it's your [ __ ] art in your home
but stories is just like whatever
so people produce like crazy for stories
but are [ __ ] crippled by the main
theme I just treat the main feeds like
stories better than most
[Music]